I was at a club one night these three
big Indian dudes surrounded me at this
pushing up against the wall surrounded
me there two one here one here one in
front of me and they're like we don't
like the jokes you're making and you're
don't disrespect and I'm like the guy's
Pok me and as soon I just went pop pop
and I just got the out of there I
hit all three of them and I ran out the
clown really so even back then
are you being serious yeah yeah yeah you
beat up three Indian dudes three dudes
like I was surrounded I had no choice if
why I didn't do that they're going to
beat the out of me it's at that
point you go go for it you really do you
do have that what what do they call
internalized
Brown phobia whatever it is it's uh no
it's fight or flight